[Music]  we thought we should have a tall  celebrity cameo for this show because  all the guests are tall so we thought we  should have a tall celebrity cameo  measuring in at six feet four inches  here's our good friend joel mchale  [Applause]  wow  that's nice she's great  thanks uh  thanks for being here oh i'm really glad  to help out conan after all whether  you're on a sitcom or a talk show we're  all part of the same community are we  not  why don't you just plug your show that's  clearly what you're here to do just plug  the show watch community thursday nights  conan i wanted to do something in this  segment that would make it go viral i  have no idea what that is but um  i'm just hoping maybe you could think of  something  if you do please let me know joel mchale  everybody i'll let you  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  we have a great uh show on our time  it's vibrating over in the corner  clearly near a microphone i didn't  intend to do that  [Applause]